chief executive Steven Fitzpatrick joins
me now so Steven welcome to you is
British gas bowing to the inevitable I
don't think anything that's been
announced today is particularly
newsworthy actually I mean as far as
we're concerned we're delighted to talk
to you about it but as far as we're
concerned it doesn't really matter what
we call energy tariffs or energy plans
it's how much customers end up paying
for the energy that they're using and
also the help that they're getting from
their energy companies to use less so it
just changed in the name I don't think
it's going to make any difference at all
and you say this because British Gas is
saying if people don't move on to a
tariff at the end of that term they'll
put them on an emergency tariff which is
essentially start a variable tariff in
all but name then I think the one thing
that we'd like to see from the
government and from the regulator and
from our the energy industry as a whole
is a real focus and helping get the
costs in the sector down so that the
cost renewables the cost of networks the
cost of energy efficiency the cost of
electric vehicle infrastructure and if
we can encourage companies and the
network providers to focus on costs then
you'll see energy bills coming down if
we just change the names of tariffs it's
a bit like shuffling the deck chairs but
this rule blow a bit of a hole in
British Gas is profit so when's it at
the moment some 60% of their customers
are on standard variable terrace and yet
they generate seventy percent of their
profits maybe even more I mean it's it's
quite hard to tell and but I don't think
changing the name of the tariff is going
to make a blow in and British gases
profits what I would say is that if the
price that customers pay comes down that
will certainly impact energy company
profits if they can't reduce their cost
as well we think energy companies should
be more efficient they should be working
harder to be better at what they do to
be better at billing to be better at the
meter readings to be better and helping
customers get more under the energy that
they're using if they were better at it
they would have lower costs and
customers would pay less so what we'd
like to see and we encourage the
government and the regulator to
completely ignore any attempts to rename
or rebrand standard variable tariffs and
focus on a simple well executed price
cap that will protect millions of
customers from overcharging save maybe
up to 1.5 billion points
you and will lead to greater efficiency
across the energy network
I'm very briefly Steven what have you
made of the German owners of empower
offloading the business and merging it
with ssese consumer on well I think this
is probably a response to more
competitive pressure it's one thing that
we want to see more off this this merger
I don't think it will affect the market
particularly it may help customers of
those two companies if they can find
efficiencies and lower costs and but
ultimately this is a reaction to
increasing pressure over time and the
inevitability of more price regulation
so it's probably a good thing for the
market as a whole or a Steven
Fitzpatrick from over energy appreciate
you joining it's good to see you